really one of the things I really try to
do very consciously in the book is to
track a particular evolution of that
process and part of what I show is that
even though we had all these asylums in
the 1930s and 40s and 50s where we
locked away all of these people there
was this and often for long periods of
time but not always there was this
assumption that we were kind of treating
people in a certain kind of way that
there was a possible recuperation or
cure obviously didn't happen for a lot
of people but you know there was an
investment I mean people were being
locked away but they were also seen as
responsibilities particularly in
schizophrenia of the state and and part
of what happens with this definitional
and racial change in the way
schizophrenia is understood in the 60s
is a feeling that these people aren't
just docile dependents of the state
they're also threats to the state
particularly with schizophrenia you see
a lot of concern that these people could
escape and kill people or they could
threaten our political order and
particularly in the 1960s when
schizophrenia becomes linked to civil
rights protests it's also schizophrenia
can bring down the state in a very you
know if this has happened in other
country so it's not surprising but we
don't often think about that in the
United States but I think part of why
schizophrenia got linked to civil rights
protests in the 60s was because
mainstream society was coding threats
against the smooth running of the state
as insanity and treating it as such and
so as that happens you see the evolution
of a process in which people with
schizophrenia are increasingly feared
and our hospitals particularly the kind
of hospital that I look at in the book
become to look more and more like like
prisons to the point where many of them
including the one I talked about
actually become prisons and that's
something that didn't just happen near
Detroit where I look but across the
country according to Human Rights Watch
for example in the present day if you
are a person died
with schizophrenia and you are in a
state institution your chances are
exponentially greater that that
institution is going to be prison rather
than a hospital
Bernard Harcourt a law professor at the
University of Chicago talks about the
transformation from a hospital based
institution to a prison based
institution and it's something that
happened across the country and that
happened obviously for many reasons but
part of it is this transformation in
which prisons became our de facto mental
hospitals and we saw mental illness as
in some way threatening not just to the
people who suffered from it but also to
us mainstream society